okay so he goes all this car I wanted to
say but you guys have too much teaching
your buddy gone the whole idea of this
power and you have a difference in the
hands is that this is percussive so if I
was gonna punch I don't hold flexion
boom the flexion might be somewhere down
there but it can't travel the flesh and
the jaws very whipped like with the
strike
okay let's go okay we need you to take
me let's say let's say he's here okay
I have to be in his center so I could
move him do you see I'm not out here
like this
no okay in his center in the center
every time in his second this
opportunity when I do the weapon so he
has his Vulcan in Seguin right and the
pressures here but it's innocent all the
time not not out there in the center so
when I do the monkeytoes it's not here
at his hand
the energy has to be going into indecent
make these bottom moves faster yes
take care now how dare you can just
swing it shoulder you see now send it
down in the center take any still any on
it and you should feel the same thing
same thing is this okay let's go right
okay so the basic strategy is very
common you
and you pursue violence of action
you understand so we're having through
that gravitational check but starting
already
that kind of onslaught okay so we're
going to do the same thing and the hard
part for the beginner is you're going to
do things like because you want to just
chase them but it can't be pitter-patter
because you can't empowers me and I'm
just here to get it okay so the beginner
always short changes the Atocha feet and
goes into the ski complete each cycle of
action fully because you're not as
successful as you think you are by just
trying to hurry up this is a signal flow
do you have to have power so we're going
to add the ski this is an Brianna
get that chat going
[Applause]
[Music]
no you're not taking me out I see
we need that so we can earn the
attending otherwise there's no chemistry
okay just like if I want you to learn
about the florets try it's got action
your shrine okay so because your HIV is
not attendant right you're just riding
this side you getting checked out there
okay if my source wings over here I'm in
trouble
my my wolf hat should go here but it's
still stuck turn you see she withdraws
its not being bounced off that would be
plus we don't want plus we don't want -
it's very small you pay 10 it just
disappears hey has you had a baby
you seen your face okay but you have to
a bit is my center so I'm not just
sitting here
there's no power it's to tension high
it's got to be a ballistic it's got to
make this like this okay let's get you
Kimmy good you know
which which raise your weapon
Lesley hold your weapon please
I'm not any safer because
weapons John that way
keep falling
[Music]
ring